ми готові робити усе що буде потрібно і
так довго Як буде потрібно щоб Україна
перемогла бачу рішучість у всіх наших
столицях зокрема у Берліні не кинути
Україну у цій епічній боротьбі Ми ніколи
не зможемо повернутися до ситуації коли
ми залежатимемо від російського
викупного палива говорячи в Україні ви
стане та членом ЄС і в Євросоюз також
обирає новий курс і це потрібно
переварити в усіх наших державах членах
на Україну чекає неймовірне майбутнє бо
населення виявило таку мужність таку
рішучість і таку єдність для вільної
України немає нічого неможливого
виконавчий віце-президента timermans
Німеччина Та Франція Минулого тижня
оголосили що відправлять броньовані
машини до України крім того Німеччина
пообіцяла поставити систему ппу Patriot
це речі про які влада у Києві просить
уже доволі давно Чи це сигнал того що
уряди країн ЄС готові зробити більше для
підтримки України
Я думаю що Україна заслуговує на всю
нашу підтримку військовому плані тому що
Жорстокість з якою діють росіяни не має
майже тож знаєте це не просто війна за
Україну це не просто спроба Росії
захопити територію сусідньої країни це
війна за майбутнє Європи це війна за
майбутнє демократії проти автократії і
той факт що український народ з такою
рішучістю та пристрастю бореться за свою
свободу має бути чітким сигналом для
Європейського Союзу що ми маємо
підтримати українців усіма наявними у
нас засобами тому я думаю що це логічний
крок зроблений Францією Німеччиною та
іншими країнами щоб підтримати Україну у
воєнному плані цими броньованими
машинами
чи достатньо цієї підтримки до перших
роковин повномасштабного вторгнення в
Україну залишилася лічні тижня багато
хто тут у Києві побоюється що Білорусь
може бути використана як плацдарм для
другої атаки другої спроби взяти Київ чи
достатньо зусиль робить ЄС у графік Ну я
думаю ви знаєте що ЄС робить достатньо
але можливо потрібно більше фінансова
підтримка наразі становить 38 млрд євро
18 мільярдів на 2023 рік цього
недостатньо щоб покрити усі витрати але
це дуже-дуже добрий крок у правильному
напрямку і ми сподіваємося що зможемо
переконати інших потенційних донорів
також долучитися знаєте для нас програш
України у цій війні просто неприпустимий
бо йдеться про наш спосіб життя і нашу
свободу тому якщо буде потрібно більше
ЄС підтримає і зараз ми робимо більше
ніж будь-хто міг передбачити раніше і з
розвитком ситуації є готовий зробити ще
більше якщо це буде необхідно і я також
бачу рішучість у всіх наших столиціях
зокрема у Берліні не кинути Україну у
цій епічній боротьбі
згадали що уряди країн ЄС зобов'язалися
виділити мільярди євро на військову та
надзвичайну допомогу але Як довго вони
зможуть підтримувати ці зусилля з огляду
на економіку інфляцію І наприклад
зростання цін на енергоносії в Європі
вважаю що ми зможемо вийти з цієї
ситуації Тільки в тому випадку якщо
Росія зрозуміє що ми готові триматися за
Україну І що ми готові робити усе що
буде потрібно і так довго Як буде
потрібно щоб Україна перемогла Отже усі
інші міркування Я думаю менш важливі ніж
те що йдеться про майбутнє Європи про
свободу Європи та про європейську
демократію і я думаю ви знаєте високі
ціни на енергоносії залишатимуться
високими доти доки Путін зможе
шантажувати людей своєю енергією ці ціни
залишатимуться високими доти доки ми не
здійснимо енергетичний перехід на
відновлювальні джерела який нам
необхідний І знаєте поступитися агресії
Путіна абсолютно неправильна відповідь
на цей виклик
говорячи про енергетичний перехід торік
стало очевидною одна річ висока
залежність ЄС від викопних видів палива
що надходять із Росії Німеччина була
найбільшим імпортером російського газу
як це змінилося у 2022 році Який план на
2023 рік з огляду на залежність від
викопного палива та зменшення залежності
від таких країн як Росія
Я думаю що це щось особливе що менш ніж
за рік ЄС зміг знизити свою газову
залежність від Росії Яка становила понад
40%, до 10%. Таким чином ми просунулися
досить швидко і особливо Німеччина чия
промисловість так сильно залежить від
російського газу змогла перелаштуватися
дуже швидко і це також завдяки дуже
сильному керівництву уряду Німеччини але
ще більше значення має також готовність
народу виявити свою Солідарність з
Україною єдине що ми можемо зробити і
маємо продовжувати робити це насамперед
економити більше енергії і це тема Про
яку хотілося б щоби більше людей
говорили на енергетичних ринках існує
величезна невідповідність між попитом та
пропозицією якщо ми не скоротимо попит
то поставки не збільшиться в один момент
тоді розрив у цінах збережеться і ціни
залишаться високими Тому нам потрібно
робити більше для зниження попиту Тому
нам потрібно заощаджувати більше енергії
по-друге нам потрібно прискорити перехід
на відновлювальні джерела енергії і ми
маємо зробити все можливе щоб
пришвидшити цей процес одне із питань
яке Нам необхідно вирішити у терміновому
порядку це отримання дозволів щоб
дозволи на будівництво вітрових
електростанцій морських вітрових
електростанцій сонячних батарей
видавалися швидше щоб ми могли починати
будувати ці об'єкти і по-третє Нам
необхідно диверсифікувати виробництво
Нам доведеться підписати контракти з
іншими компаніями з іншими
постачальниками головного палива по
всьому світу таким чином щоб ми не
залежали від одного чи двох з них а
диверсифікували свою енергетику і так
далі зрештом ми маємо повністю прийти на
відновлювальні джерела енергії щоб нам
більше не потрібно було викопне паливо
але це займе чимало часу і Протягом
наступних 10-15 років Ми все ще
залишитимемо від викопного палива але
вже з інших джерел Ми ніколи не зможемо
повернутися до ситуації коли ми
залежатимемо від російського викопного
палива
Отже ми говорили про постачання зброї
фінансову допомогу структурні зміни у
галузі енергетики ще одна річ яка
здається дуже важливою для людей в
Україні це не лише допомога а й
партнерство Україна хоче стати партнером
хоче стати членом Європейського Союзу
торік їй дали статус кандидата
Чи можете ви сказати чого очікувати у
2023 році чи є якісь конкретні кроки Які
би могли б оголосити
насамперед Я думаю ми маємо усвідомити
історичну важливість кандидатури України
та статусу кандидата у члени ЄС за все
моє життя це лише друга справді велика
політична подія яка спрямовує нашу
історію в іншу русло першою було падіння
Берлінського Муру У
1989 році і це друга усі інші історичні
події як на мене вторинні стосовно цих
двох Тому ми маємо розуміти що говорячи
в Україні ви станете членом ЄС Євросоюз
також обирає новий курс і це потрібно
переварити в усіх наших державах членах
Це дійсно те що подібно до розширення у
2004 році змінить сутність Європейського
Союзу по-друге щоб довести що це не
просто політика та не просто розмови нам
треба показати насправді що ми можемо
зробити щоб наблизити Україну до
Європейського Союзу Я думаю якщо ви
поглянете на те що Україна зробила за
останні місяці у плані ухвалення
законодавства що відповідає семи вимогам
які були встановлені для набуття статусу
кандидата то це відповідає цьому процесу
на шляху до членства в ЄС ми маємо
відповісти на це сказавши в Україні
добре ви ухвалили це законодавство тепер
найближчими роками Ми допоможемо вам
реалізувати це законодавство і ми надамо
вам підтримку щоб зробити цю реалізацію
успішною так само як ми зробили це після
1989 року з країнами які є членами ЄС із
2004 року цей процес підготовки до
вступу буде надзвичайно важливим але ми
маємо розпочати його негайно конкретно
особливо в галузі енергетичного переходу
ми маємо виявити Солідарність з Україною
ми маємо зробити її частиною майбутньою
водневої економіки ЄС Україна ідеально
підходить для того щоб стати величезним
виробником зеленого водню та біометану
які необхідні для чистої економіки
Європи майбутнього
чи може Україна стати членом
Європейського Союзу коли На її території
все ще стоять російські війська це
можливо
ні це неможливо але вся ідея полягає в
тому щоб Україна вийшла з цього
конфлікту переможницею суверенною
незалежною вільною державою та мала
змогу зробити цей вибір самостійно і я
думаю що Україна виборює те щоб це
сталося європейські Союз має підтримати
Україну у досягненні цієї мети і щойно
цієї мети буде досягнуто на Україну
чекає неймовірне майбутнє бо населення
виявило таку мужність таку рішучість і
таку єдність для вільної України немає
нічого неможливого
президента Франція тімерманц дякую вам